I'm very grateful for being here to
share with you that I live in a country
Uruguay where about 98% of it
electricity is obtained from a
combination of different renewable
sources a country whose inhabitants emit
30 times less greenhouse gases than the
world average for each kilowatt hour
consumed a country that produces its
electricity at fixed cost regardless of
wars or other geopolitical events since
it is almost independent on energy
Commodities dependent just on its wind
its Sun its water it's biomass waste a
country that exports renewable energy
surpluses to its two giant neighbors
Argentina and Brazil when I tell people
about Euro they usually say two things I
never heard about it how did you do it
and can this be replicated elsewhere so
today I want to tell you what happened
in U how would it it and yes even if
every country who had to Define its own
transition Journey the ugan solution can
definitely be replicated as well 15
years ago the U energy sector was going
to a deep
crisis economy was growing and
unprecedented rates and poverty was
increasing was so great of course but at
the same
time energy demand was growing rapidly
which was not so great uguay has no
proven reserve for fossil fuels we have
already used our large rivers to install
hydrop power plants and our two many
neighbors were having their own
difficulties to supply internal demand
so it was not easy for them to help us
in dry years when you have to import
much more fossil fuels or we were forced
to import electricity from our neighbors
at extraordinary prices cost of runs
could be as high as $1 billion and for a
small economy like Uruguay the this is
2% of his GDP and we're still we're
beginning to have blackouts we're living
The Perfect Storm but crisis is also
opportunity for most of my life I was a
scientist a political physicist doing
research on subjects far removed from
the everyday world but in that
particular National energy context I saw
the need to reinvent myself to get
involved in the sear for Solutions I
began to study the energy issue to
organize seminars to discuss with
different experts and I realize how
complex the energy issue is how many
dimensions it has technological and
economical dimensions of course but also
environmental social geopolitical
cultural and even ethical Dimensions I
started to write down my thoughts and
almost without realizing it I ended up
with a comprehensive holistic proposal
focus on adjust transition to renewable
energies with very ambitious goals calls
and one day when I was in my office at
University I received an unexpected call
my proposal had the president and he was
inviting me to implement it imagine my
surprise he was inviting me to be the
political head of our national energy
agency what in United States would be
the Secretary of Energy I accepted and
we immediately began to implement that
policy but before the result could be
fully seen there was an election
fortunately the new president Jose moika
was supported of what we were had
started to do and he asked me to remain
in office but he asked me one important
point to make this policy to be accepted
by all political
parties patiently we negotiated with all
parties represented in Parliament and we
achieve our goal after accepting s minus
changes having a long-term policy backed
by the entire uruan political system was
crucial to make rapid progresses in just
5 years we went from a traditional
hydrothermal power mix with up to 50% FY
share to an almost completely
decarbonized one that already in 2017
was 98% renewable what makes ugan cage
unique is that almost half of that
electricity is obtained from
non-traditional renewable sources wind
solar and sustainable
biomass wind alone can produce up to 40%
of the total electricity consumed in the
country in a year a percentage
comparable to the other world win
Champion Denmark but also 15 or even 20%
of our electricity is obtained with
sustainable biomass uruguai is an
agroindustrial country with abundant
organic waste that has a lot of energy
content like rice house by gas black
liquid from Power Mills they have now
ceased to be an environmental liability
to become an energy asset of course none
of this was easy we have to innovate we
have to understand that a such a power
system requires the planning and
operation quite different than the
traditional one our academics work for
years to design a groundbreaking
software to handle energy dispatch
specifically designed to manage
intermittent sources such as wind and
solar but also how to use water
this model is based on the probability
of occurrence of different weather
scenarios basing both asent of
historical data and weather forecast
this allows us for example to have a
prediction of the amount of wind
electricity and solar electricity that
we're going to have in the grid with a
weak in advance and this also allows us
to know how and when we have to use
water from the dams thank to this
disruptive methodology today in Uruguay
intermittent sources are King the total
isal capacity of wind plus solar is of
the order of the total country's Pi
demand this means that when we have
enough wind and solar Almost 100% of
electricity is just from these two
sources alone in addition to biomass
fire power plant and this may happen
many times during the course of a week
and in those moments we don't use water
from the dams hydrop power plant only
come into play when the Sun goes go down
or when the wind
Falls our insurance policy when all
sales fails are gas turbines combined
cycle and engine power plant yes of
course flexible fossil fire power plant
remain there but we rely on them very
little over the course of a year
allowing nonrenewable electricity to be
much more than 2% of the electricity in
the Grid in a regular year and sometimes
six or seven 7% in a very dry by one and
get this we achiev this goal without any
single battery storage water pumping or
any modern technology for electricity
storage uru has shown that a power mix
can work almost exclusively thanks to
the complementarity of different
renewable sources independently of their
individual
intermittency and this is perhaps the
time for you to ask the question and
what happened to the economy how much
all this
cost and the answer is even more radical
the cost was negative if I may put it
this way in fact we get an impressive
positive impact to our economy to begin
with the total cost to produce
electricity all over a year was you use
was almost half no surprise renewable
energies are the cheapest option today
we went from about $1.1 billion cost to
only $600 million today and this
impressive $500 million every year for a
country like Uruguay is huge it's 1% of
its GDP just for comparison 1% of United
States GDP is about $250 billion
annually moreover those tremendous cost
of runs that we had in dry years well
they vitally disappeared we went from
coast over RS of about $1 billion to
only 100 to perhaps 200 million a year
in a very dry ones surprisingly enough
now that we have much more natural
sources in the grid because of their
complimentarity we are much less
dependent on wether
variability of course achieving this
tremendous cost reduction was not easy
either we have to innovate also on that
we have to understand that renewable
energies weire a business model quite
different from the traditional one of
the power sect all over the world we
have to create a new market model our
present business model is based on
long-term contracts during from auction
processes in which the percentage of his
source is predetermined using an
optimization model that defines which is
the best technical complementarity
between sources in order to minimize the
overall cost of the
system thanks to this nowaday almost 100
% of our electricity generation is under
contract leaving almost no space for
sport market and also no space for
uncertainties the comprehensive model we
have defined and put in place not only
allows us to strongly reduce the overall
cost but also to stabilize it over time
the cost to produce electricity in
uruguai today is stabilized think is is
almost independent on the fluctuation of
the prices of energy commodities
thanks to this for example the Uruguayan
electric mix was barely affected by the
tragic war in Europe we had no Supply
nor affordability difficulties but the
positive economic impact of this
transformation went far beyond just the
electric sector we achieved a tremendous
impact to our economy we received $6
billion investment this is 12% of our
GDP imagine the impact to our economy
new knowledge new industrial
entrepreneurial capabilities 50,000 jobs
were created this seems small perhaps
for you but for a country with only 3.4
million inhabitants you represent 3% of
its labor force once again we made to
make a comparison 3% of United States
lab forces several million new jobs
creation so I told you a little about
what happened in Uruguay and how we did
it but you may be thinking okay but
that's Uruguay fine but that's Uruguay
it's a small country they have a unique
culture they have hydro can this be
reproduced as well so I want to be very
emphatic on this although each country
will have to Define its own transition
process the vast majority of country can
make a process similar to the ran
one you don't necessarily need a lot of
hyro up capacity but for sure you need
to put much more flexibility to your
system with new dispatch model a new
market model but you have people and
companies doing research and developing
Ai and artificial artificial
intelligence and Rockets developing a
new market model a new Energy Management
shouldn't be that hard by doing this we
will probably not get the fossil share
down to 2% but for sure it will be below
15 or even 20% and in many countries
much less than that and you what for the
last couple of years after living
governments I've been working in in a
number of countries from Dominican
Republic to Chile and many other
countries in Latin America but also in
Europe in other regions and the good
news is that the Uruguayan solution can
work in different National and energy
context but for that there is one
special ingredient you need to have a
strong leadership and a strong political
will to move forwards and for that
it's mostly recommended to build a broad
political agreement that transcends the
administration in office in order to be
sure that the transition will continue
in time what is then the most important
message for you today it is very simple
that Renewables are no longer just a
solution for the climate crisis
Renewables allows us to build strong
reliable robust power system they allow
us to sh ly reduce and stabilize the
electricity cost while at the same time
having an important energy boost to our
economies
and job
creation Lessons Learned From the
Uruguayan case is that renewable
energies are right to provide not just a
clent solution on a global scale but
also substantial socioeconomic benefits
at a local level and this can and should
happen now there's no reason to wait
until 2040 not even
2030 now thank
you